battlefield has been one of my favorite
franchises ever since i would sneak
downstairs onto the family computer to
play 1942
almost 20 years ago almost 20 years ago
the franchise has obviously come a long
way since then
and from what we've seen of 2042 so far
is making yet
another leap from the franchise that a
lot of the fans may be
intimately familiar with so what does
that mean for the series
dice is calling this its next generation
of battlefield so it makes sense that it
will make a departure from the games
that came before it
and while it may be early days so far
from what i've seen it seems like the
objective is to make a battlefield
experience that's new
but has enough for veterans of the
series to stick around as well
a lot of the emphasis was put on
creating battlefield moments that the
franchise has become so famous for
those experiences are quintessentially
tied to the series
the larger than life takedowns
destruction and kills that can create
either
epic moments that stick with you long
after the round was won
or more bizarre almost slapstick
instances
that sit at complete odds to
battlefield's otherwise
largely serious and grounded gameplay
and i am all for that my immediate
reaction was pure oil
hell yeah more battlefield and while i
understand that this is a move that may
be influenced by
keeping the battlefield experience
interesting and shareable online
an aspect that a lot of shooters have
really thrived off of
in recent years just look at twitter and
all the war zone clips
it also means this next entry in the
series is as much
a playground as it is a virtual field of
combat
it also appears that alongside that
action sandbox there is also a huge
drive towards more diversity
variety and dynamism in the interactions
players have within battlefield
and in the ways that they are able to
play now let me see at this point i'm so
glad the franchise is returning to a
modern slash near future setting i
really enjoyed my time with battlefield
1 and 5 but i always gravitate back to
bf4
and i think the reason behind that is
that the modern or future backdrop
always provides more variety
than the titles from historical
conflicts is this a slight pull away
from battlefield being known as one of
the
realistic first-person shooter options
in the fps genre
i mean maybe some of the things that
dice are adding
can sort of be seen as a little bit
silly like the overly dramatic weather
the wing suits robot dogs
rising sea levels dwindling resources
no no some of those are real but if the
rest are implemented in that same old
battlefield fashion that
everything else is then i can't see why
these new maybe
over-the-top wrinkles and tools and
resources
and options and gadgets can't
comfortably fit
into the game by bumping to the near
future and creating its own setting and
backstory
dice no longer has to stick to conflicts
between countries
powers or already known factions it may
be without a single player campaign
something that i'm honestly not too
fussed about losing if the multiplayer
makes up for it
but the story they're telling via their
online experience has players taking the
role of a non-patriotic soldier
it's a natural avenue to create more
diversity in the individual combatant
as well as their equipment vehicles and
even settings
basically being a soldier of the world
means that you can come from
any background use any equipment and
have
any experiences to bring into the
battlefield and the maps and locations
are only possible with this direction
i mean hell yeah i want to wingsuit from
buildings and ride a tornado
damn right i want to chase enemies on
atvs through sandstorms and darn
two in your boy wants to zipline across
skyscrapers
none of that could really be done
without a move like this
and exploring the near-ish fictional
timeline without going as far as
revisiting 2142
is the perfect place for it and while
you can sort of see the real world
parallels that have
influenced this fictional world it can
still be matched with battlefield
quote-unquote
realism as well as having that
playground experience
this is after all the series where every
soldier has a parachute to deploy
at any time atvs are launched into
helicopters and pilots eject from
fighter jets
to snipe at enemy planes to me it's
always felt like these were moments that
you
could do in battlefield but now i get
the feeling that these are things dice
actively
wants you to do which again goes hand in
hand with this new playground that it's
building
during the press event where we got to
see a little of the game just before the
live stream announcement the folks at
dice were using the term battlefield
moments
a lot it's a term that they've used
across marketing for the franchise in
the past all the way since
around bad company 2 but it definitely
feels like an element they're
really driving forward with now and
veterans of the series might remember
battlefield bad company 2
was the most sort of slapstick silly
that the franchise has ever been
and that's what birthed battlefield
moments they want that same
creativity almost silliness again with
2042
for example being able to call in
vehicles anywhere on the map is going to
make
some stupid daft massive atv jumps while
tanks being dropped on top of buildings
just to shoot down choppers
and i admit while i wasn't too sold on
the premise at first i will hold my hand
up and say
that i do in fact want to throw c4 onto
my robot gun turret dog
and launch it off of a building in the
middle of some blade runner-esque city
now i have no way of knowing this for
certain but i get the impression that in
some of these design meetings the
decisions weren't so much
will this work in a battlefield game
more
will this be bloody cool in a
battlefield game
and i firmly believe that there is room
for the whole spectrum
especially with the matches being so
much bigger than before on massive maps
with 128 players
and why the hell not make room for the
daft memorable moments as well as the
intense fire fights and squad play
that sticks with you this can be your
battlefield
however you want to play whatever you
want to accomplish in the game being one
of 64 players on your team in a battle
of 128
gives you space to experiment and
experience new things
at your own pace new elements like
vehicles having new seats that actually
do stuff let new players always feel
useful
and more variety and bigger space in
more maps can let
soldier hone in on a preferred playstyle
additions to modes like conquests with
wider objectives and sectors over the
maps and the opportunity for more varied
gameplay on each map is so exciting
for the longest time a lot of
battlefield maps have been connected to
either vehicle or infantry combat
as part of their identity but i'm super
stoked to be able to experience
every facet of gameplay within the same
instance and dice also talked about what
it calls varied pacing
which aims to create both a hectic
feverish fights that the whole team
takes part in
as well as the smaller skirmishes over
objectives now this is also a grand
assumption i don't know this for sure
but i'm expecting we'll be seeing a
whole slew of customization options for
your soldiers and vehicles
after all battlefield 4 had skins and
battlefield 5 had their own uniforms and
more detailed cosmetics
since this is a live service game it
makes sense that the content will be
dropped in the same way or via their new
seasonal battle passes
and from what i could see in the trailer
there were all sorts of uniforms pieces
of equipment helmets and
camouflage adorning the combatants now
i'm not in love with everything i've
seen so far
part of being able to admire something
is seeing its flaws right that's
probably something my therapist said but
the on-the-fly weapon customization for
example who's
carrying all those scopes and barrels
and magazines around
personally i'd prefer the traditional
loadout system
respawn change your weapons but saying
that
battlefield 2042 so far is
ticking a lot of boxes for me there are
doses of nostalgia in there for veterans
of the series like
base jumping throwbacks to devaman peak
there's also a bunch for players that
are fairly new to the franchise and
seemingly a lot of cool new stuff
for those who have not yet experienced
glory in battlefield and i think this
push towards the playground sandbox and
dice's renewed mentions of those
battlefield moments
are going to be really important to keep
the player base healthy
and the game talked about social media
is always
filled with those clips and notable
moments from games like warzone and
fortnite and they do a lot
to keep the player base coming back and
introduce new players and remind people
that this game does in fact exist come
play it and battlefield really pioneered
that stuff with the battlefield moments
they wanted you to do
all the over-the-top silly stuff and
create stories around them
so it makes a lot of sense that they
want to be back in the conversation now
if that comes hand-in-hand with a bigger
broader and more assorted battlefield
experience then as a longtime fan
i'm all bloody for it the younger me
playing 1942
would really go bananas seeing this game
i hope you enjoyed the video if you have
your own thoughts and opinions please
let me know in the comment section down
below or reach out to me on twitter at a
regular dave i'd love
to hear what your thoughts are be you a
battlefield a veteran or someone just
joining the franchise either way make
sure you subscribe because we're gonna
have a lot more coverage
over the next few weeks and months but
until then thank you so much for
watching
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you